[Music]
you
[Music]
don't care i do love you but what the
way you treat me since you decided to
end things with mine what qualities are
you looking for
i just like to be in charge keep
drinking darcy you don't love me you
never did you buy her with darcy it was
never meant to be
but i'm still looking for this pure soul
this beauty
being with erica was very stressful and
i haven't had sex in two and a half
years there is a world of possibilities
i want to be a housewife with someone
who doesn't want to give me anything
me and tanya we're splitting up so i'm
open to meeting a gothic girl a nun if
nones even dates
i'm done put your hands to me i called
the police yes i am colt's mom but it's
been 40 years since i've been on a date
i'm looking for someone that i really
care about and can enjoy my experience
sexually
in my here forever
this breakup is one of the hardest
things i've ever done in my life i'm
ready for big ed 2.0
oh my goodness
i'm sorry i lost in your eyes
i just want family and child i just want
a good guy just good guy
back in 2007 i died for 30 minutes
missionary doggy it's footy
i am trying to lose my celibacy to
somebody
that i could be a hoe with my homemade
[Music]
i feel
like a virgin rediscovering like
whoa
it feels
like i'm falling in love with you
daily team was a complete disaster it
was terrible
but i do believe that i will fall in
love with jesse but i've been dating
someone else too
i hope we can be friends i don't want to
be like
stop
blaming me for
like i am not here to make you happy
anymore i'm done bro
i'm really nervous there's a lot on the
line but i deserve to have love
do new
you